[Música]
o
ots pessoal de quem fala em mudar que
seja muito bem vindo já mais de um vídeo
e arroz trabalho já que com vídeo de
frente é verdade a outro vídeo enfrentou
ondas cheguem lá estar folha ontem fui
ao hospital fazer uma pequena cirurgia
que estava marcada por tempo vejo a
minha carinha você já é melhor parar que
andei aqui procurar muito gozo e não sei
se vocês repararam alguma vez me senti
que tinha que vários sinais na cara e
não estavam intestinais e também os
cursos já estavam aumentar um pouco
tanto já não já não tava que está a
acontecer e consultar um médico e ver o
que eu podia fazer e estava tudo bem
comigo não estava porque eles vão
aumentar o sport também estavam a
aumentar por causa do verão do sol que
andava apanhar eu devia ter mais cuidado
com o papel não é coisa que não fazia
mas de qualquer forma tive de colocar os
sinais porque não dava já eu procurei
então é se um dia eu aproveitei filme
também um popular é de vocês virem este
vídeo antes disso tudo não vai num
comentário do arquivo alegre cidade que
você possui esse pitt é um jeito cara
porque é e se vocês não querem ver
coisas nojentas x5 vídeo tá um pouco no
gente porque o cortam os sinais que
peluso laser e usou faca bisturi meu mas
se vocês não querem ver coisas nojentas
estão os primeiros não querem se
surpreende com algo que nos vai afetar
um pouco estômago não vejo ciclos muito
vídeo e vamos embora vamos fazer coisas
fluídos e porque eu vou estar este vídeo
porque achei interessante a forma como
os sinais estão no vídeo e pelo som mais
zeloso misture e o filme porque o jogo
estava ver o que é que eu não vejo a
cara porque temos condições já tinha na
época o laser é muito forte e por que
não aproveitar e explorar um bloco com
um vídeo pra que vocês mais um como é
que ter tirado e agora isso vai demorar
que uma duas semanas a recuperar
portanto nestes vídeos próximos que vão
sair eu voltar assim colocar toda
fechada nas propostas por semana é
espírito convido a opressão espero que
vocês gostem fiquem bem e até a próxima
antes que eu esqueça pessoal passa pelo
canal desse trio porque o meu vídeo
deste da cirurgia também continua lá
portanto se quiserem ver mais podem ver
lá ela ainda não gostou mas vai estar em
breve portanto acompanhe porque ela vai
começar o starlux comigo também que
pular nossa vida tipo nossa rotina vejam
um link para a inscrição passa por lá
deixou
[Música]
pensa em coisas boas pb estou cansado
não se provou que é puxado por que o
senhor paz ao ie6 unesco vai até o lábio
superior
[Música]
leão
piu piu
[Música]
não
acho que vai acontecer agora
agora um aplicado é um ensaio diferente
recursos e tirou mateus borges não comum
é bom o fato é que é
[Música]
parece um acidente de carro eu sei agora
o dermatologista e já me pediram para
tirar uma foto com o inscrito a e existe
uma pessoa que tenha foto mais caro do
mundo que com esta coisa na cara sendo
acontecer mais que o cara eu não sinto
este dentro aqui aparece um desdentado
está melhor tá lindo fiquei com uma
excursão marvel nos comentários e anos
dizia olha isto diz tudo branco week com
a injeção to